rellena los espacios en blanco para
formar un sistema de ecuaciones lineales
con las variables x y jeff con
soluciones infinitas y bueno si vamos a
tener una infinidad de soluciones
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es hablar de la misma recta deben de ser
la misma ecuación y deben tener la misma
construcción así que por ejemplo si aquí
partimos con esta que es menos 5 x más 7
igual a 1 y si nosotros queremos ver la
gráfica de cómo se vería bueno pues
déjame dibujar aquí a un par de ejes voy
a decir que este es mi eje de las 10 y
por acá tengo a mi eje de las x ok
vamos a poner que este es mi eje james
ok este es mi eje x y si yo quisiera
graficar esta función que tengo aquí
bueno qué te parece si a esta la pasamos
a su forma pendiente ordenada al origen
y para eso voy a despejar allí
me va a quedar siete veces y es lo mismo
que este va a pasar para acá
del otro lado con signo positivo estoy
sumando 5x de ambos lados entonces me
quedaría 5x + 1 ok ahora nos falta
quitar este 7 y para quitar este 7 voy a
dividir todo todo entre 7 y por lo tanto
me va a quedar clique es lo mismo que es
5 entre 7 por equis estoy dividiendo
todo entre 7 más 1 entre 7 de lujo y si
te das cuenta aquí tenemos una recta que
es corta al eje de las 10 en el valor de
un séptimo estamos más o menos por aquí
ok esto es muy valor de un séptimo y
después tenemos una pendiente positiva
de cinco séptimos por lo tanto a la
función se vería más o menos así esta
ecuación lineal se va a ver de este
estilo
ahora si nosotros lo que queremos es
tener una infinidad de soluciones lo que
voy a buscar es que tengamos exactamente
la misma recta es decir que mi otra
recta sea
exactamente ella misma para que así cada
uno de los puntos sea una solución de
este sistema es decir estamos
superponiendo a cada equis y james que
satisfaga la primera ecuación y bueno la
forma más fácil de llegar a esta
solución es trabajando esta ecuación que
tengo aquí y manipulando la de manera
algebraica de tal manera que lleguemos a
una ecuación que sea y que represente la
misma ecuación de aquí arriba y bueno
para hacer esto aquí tenemos una clave
aquí en un inicio tenemos un 1 y este 1
va a pasar a convertirse en 3 y de aquí
de 1 a 3 lo que estoy haciendo es
multiplicar por 3 y si estoy
multiplicando por 3 y quiero que esta
ecuación se mantenga entonces todo lo
tengo que multiplicar por 3 esta parte
habrá que multiplicarlo por 3 y esta
otra parte también habrá que multiplicar
la por 3 de tal manera que voy a
multiplicar por tres toda esta igualdad
y entonces esta igualdad se va a
mantener
y se multiplicó por 3 me va a quedar 3
por menos 5 en lo cual es menos 15 ok
menos 15 x 3 por 7 21 más 21 james esto
es igual a 1 por 3 lo cual es 3 ya que
aquí ya tengo representada a la misma
ecuación porque estoy multiplicando todo
por una misma constante lo cual me
representan dos rectas exactamente
iguales y eso quiere decir que tenemos
un sistema de ecuaciones con soluciones
infinitas y de luego es justo lo que
quería ahora vamos a hacer otro otro
problema y para eso voy a quitar este
problema de aquí y vamos a traer el
siguiente problema este de aquí este es
mi otro problema y dice cuál de las
siguientes opciones de c
aquí está si resultará en un sistema de
ecuaciones lineales sin soluciones y
tengo dos ecuaciones 5x menos 2
igual a 6 10 x menos 4 james igual a
cero y vamos a marcarlo justo aquí
tenemos
y bueno si queremos no tener solución es
esencialmente tendremos que tener la
misma combinación de x de james pero
igualada a dos números distintos o bueno
tal vez otra forma de pensarlo es decir
que si gráfica mos estas dos ecuaciones
entonces tenemos dos rectas con la misma
pendiente pero que intersectan al eje y
en valores distintos ahora qué te parece
si lo pensamos de la primera forma si lo
queremos ver de la primera forma
entonces vamos a buscar que está esta
ecuación de abajo tenga la misma
construcción en x de james se vea igual
que esta ecuación de arriba solamente
que vamos a hacer que la parte izquierda
sea distinta entonces voy a manipular
esto de una manera algebraica para que
la parte izquierda se vea exactamente
igual que la parte izquierda de esta
ecuación de arriba mientras que la parte
derecha lo que vamos a hacer es justo
restringir hacer
y bueno para esto date cuenta que
estamos muy pero muy cerca entonces lo
que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre
dos voy a dividir esta ecuación entre
dos voy a dividir todo entre dos para
que así podamos obtener la misma
construcción en x y en james y si te das
cuenta vamos a llegar a lo siguiente
vamos a llegar y déjame ponerlo con este
color a 5 x 5 x menos a 4 entre 2 es 22
veces james esto es igual a c entre 2
hace entre 2 y ahora quiero que te des
cuenta que en este momento ya tenemos la
misma parte izquierda de las dos
ecuaciones es decir la misma
construcción para x para jane 5 x menos
2 james y ahora lo que queremos es que 6
que esta parte de aquí sea distinta a
esta parte de aquí porque si fueran
iguales regresaríamos al caso anterior
regresaríamos a tener la misma recta y
es más déjeme apuntarlo si se entre 2
fuera exactamente igual a 6 entonces
tenemos la misma recta tenemos la misma
recta que es el caso anterior y bueno
podemos decir que tenemos la misma recta
y entonces tenemos la misma ecuación
ecuación y entonces podemos decir que
tenemos las mismas restricciones las
mismas restricciones restricciones o que
ahora recuerda que pasó en el caso
anterior en el caso anterior teníamos la
misma recta y entonces teníamos una
infinidad de soluciones en este caso
tendríamos infinidad de soluciones
soluciones ok pero lo que queremos es no
tener una infinidad de soluciones sino
tener un sistema sin soluciones y bueno
para eso vamos a pensar qué es lo que
tenemos si se entre dos es distinto de 6
si se entre 2 esto es distinto de 6 si
se entre 2 es distinto de 6 entonces no
va a haber en ninguna
y ya que pongamos aquí que cumpla ambas
ecuaciones fíjate bien si encontramos
una equis y una ley que satisfaga la
primera ecuación entonces 5 x menos dos
sería igual a seis y si lo ponemos aquí
esto nos daría seis pero esto es algo
distinto de seis pero tanto no cumple la
otra ecuación y en este caso no estamos
encontrando un sistema de ecuaciones que
no tienen solución no tienen no tiene
solución solución ok
otra forma de verlo sería multiplicar
todo por 2 que sea distinto de 6 por 2
12 esto es un sistema que no tiene tiene
solución solución solución y bueno es
que si se fuera 12 entonces 2 entre 2
sería 6 y llegamos a este caso por lo
tanto ya podemos poner que la respuesta
es cualquier número excepto el 12
cualquier número excepto el 12 es
nuestra solución y bueno también hay
otra forma de verlo
podemos pensar que cada una de estas dos
ecuaciones se representan una recta y
por lo tanto para no tener solución es
lo que vamos a querer es que sean rectas
paralelas es decir que tengamos la misma
pendiente pero que tengamos distinta
intersección con el eje bien y bueno
para eso qué te parece si trabajamos las
dos ecuaciones y las ponemos en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen así que
déjenme empezar con la primera esta de
aquí se va a ver así si yo despejó allí
voy a obtener aunque menos dos veces y
es lo mismo que 6 menos 5 x ok lo único
que estoy haciendo es restando 5 x de
ambos lados y ahora está divido todo
entre menos 2 voy a obtener que james es
igual primero me voy a tomar a éste me
va a quedar menos entre menos más 5
medios 5 medios de x y después 6 entre
menos 2 lo cual es menos 3 ok de lujo
ahora esta ecuación es la forma
pendiente ordenar el origen de esta de
aquí si nosotros fijamos en la otra si
nos fijamos en ésta
también en la forma pendiente orden al
origen que voy a obtener que menos 2
james es igual a 5x negativo porque este
pasa con signo contrario ya esto le voy
a sumar entre 2 ok y ahora sí divido
todo todo entre menos 2 voy a obtener
que james es igual a menos entre menos
me da más 5 medios de x 5 medios x más y
aquí me quedaría todo dividido entre -2
y por lo tanto este va a ser menos c
entre 2 entre 2 me va a quedarse entre 4
y si te das cuenta estas dos rectas
tienen la misma pendiente tienen una
pendiente de 5 medios y yo lo que voy a
buscar es que no sean la misma recta es
decir que sean paralelas y para eso lo
que voy a buscar es que esta parte sean
distintas y ahora fíjate bien si
tuviéramos una c igual a 12 entonces me
quedaría 2 entre 4 lo cual es 3 y aquí
la intersección sería la misma menos
tres y menos tres por lo tanto
hablaríamos de la misma recta pero como
queremos
paralelas entonces lo que vamos a buscar
es que se sea distinto de 12 entonces lo
que vamos a pedir es que se sea
cualquier número excepto el 12 y
entonces vamos a encontrar dos rectas
paralelas